[Music]
which is yeah it's not obvious which one
is strong
i guess knight c6 the idea was long
castle yeah
and 95 queen takes d6 maybe just
uh if 95
yeah that seems that seems probable even
so queen eight is extremely sharp yeah
but hard to say of course this uh
players are calculating lots of
variations now and we are just uh
talking uh you know but so probably
there was a reason why knight d7 was
played even if
obviously knight c6 is more
healthy looking but it doesn't always
mean that it's a right move yeah
absolutely i i think the uh specifically
uh levon was looking for the more
comfortable answer to
long castles and he chose he chose 97 to
have this idea of playing queen a5
and i guess if you if you look at the
same position with the knight on c6 just
briefly
here after queen takes d6 i guess your
pieces actually start falling off maybe
and with the knight on d7 uh he probably
has some way of protecting his
his pieces in the center which he feels
is uh
more stable i don't know maybe option
rookie
maybe maybe even knight f8 which which
looks passive
yeah yeah yeah but rookie 5 is even more
direct yeah because you attack the
bishop and you want to take on a2
yeah maybe okay but it looks quite scary
for white i would be
i mean it's uh warring slightly boring
so
of course the very solid move is b3
now yeah after queen a5 probably
b3 but then of course so yeah because
now you protect
everything but maybe maybe we can
actually play g5
yeah i think so but um not completely
sure yeah g4
yeah g4 i i don't know it's uh you know
it works
it gets very messy gfc3 i have my doubts
but we can try it
dc i would like to take a rook and then
you go c3
and the point is after queen c2 we have
bishop takes f5 with the
is this made yeah i can get but i can
check first on a3 and bishop
of course yeah that's much stronger
that's much stronger yeah apologies
that seems completely winning actually
check and then bishop five and the pin
the pin wins the game because of queen
beto mate ideas
um so yeah g5 is at least
interesting we don't we don't
yeah uh bishop takes c4
it's dangerous and then 27. yeah i mean
d7 but it
doesn't work yeah i mean even at i guess
simply check on a3 bishop takes b3 i
don't yeah at least
at least we have this and at least we
have a perpetual here but probably more
probably more yeah
probably that that shouldn't work so b3
yeah very sharp position but b3 is a
solid sort of move but maybe it's not
really it's not the time
anymore to make solid moves i would
consider knight g3
even giving up the pawn on a2 is
extremely extreme
yeah i want then somehow bishop dcb
should be one but yeah it's very very
danger very dangerous yeah i agree oh
you don't even have maybe two i didn't
actually have to take yeah yeah
also but even so yeah this bishop d3985
now this doesn't look good
no we we haven't really won enough
material yeah you cannot really afford
probably
this so hang on a second there's 25
check there in the end what's happening
and if i just play queen a1 check now
um bishop is and now ah bishop five
still queen d5 so
let's see uh queen takes c4 check maybe
queen takes c for check was okay
after bishop takes c4 we go bishop c2
bishop c2 and b3
yeah there's definitely going to be
enough compensation yeah i
black might have more but these lines
that we're showing they are
yeah it's a serious choice now yeah for
for fabiano so let's see maybe let's
come back to
to the uh do the carlson game because
95 94 now a very very critical
moment of the game yeah yeah it feels
like this one is
i expected it to get here if they got
here i expected it to happen like half
an hour later but
yeah uh they both are taking these
decisions quite
uh quite quickly and uh bishop f5
of course is my it might work i mean i
uh has to be
definitely calculated yet takes takes
takes knight takes c4
yeah but there's there's bishop c2 and
now yeah takes c3 or something then
right trying to run i doubt of course
but no even
at minimum you can change queens yeah oh
yeah that that's a very big argument
against this because
with the queens off we're not really
going to be able to give any mate here
there's there's going to be some
compensation yeah serious compensation
yeah
takes and taking on
yeah e3 or b2 so
yeah there's definitely even even though
this this doesn't look quite right and i
suspect black has something smarter even
this is not
entirely clear because there's there's
players some play yeah but but
but what else for black yeah after 94
what are the other options because you
i i cannot believe you can give give up
this d6 bishop
it's uh it would be a big exposition
unpleasant yeah if you if you had to if
you had to allow this trade
it would make white's life a lot a lot
easier so we couldn't actually make
knight take c4 work at the first
the first attempt didn't work right i'm
thinking about some absolutely crazy
ideas like knight takes c4 queen takes
c4 rook takes e4
i mean that's of course looks crazy look
before
quinchito quincy a5 but i
uh it shouldn't work
[Music]
bishop d2 probably yeah queen a4 between
a4
yeah this queen before but now it's not
too much yeah yeah
it's a little bit it's a little bit too
much i think we don't really generate
enough threats immediately
white will i don't know run towards a1
very quickly
and stabilize some playful but more
absolutely practical uh some practical
chances but not objectively it's not
good probably so 94
yeah let's see what what is the magnus's
idea here
if we start with rook b4 white i guess
takes on d6 and then maybe even plays b3
right
uh the bishop on e4 will look slightly
stronger maybe bishop b3 is already
possible and then after e5 at least i
have a3 and then i can put my bishop on
a2
yeah i mean in general i would say that
uh of course once i take this bishop
i'm already a happy man with white yeah
a3
yeah definitely relatively happy of
course but because rook b6 and maybe
rook b7 somewhere black has some play
but he should play for back maybe on b3
no but then i think just playing b3
makes sense without
without doing all those things just do
it here
and we want to play something like rook
he one bishop d2 bishop c3
there are some knight g4 trying to go
queen e5 some some
tactical of course chances for black but
uh
uh it's strategically it's already not
good if before
after rookie 3 for instance it was
actually fantastic strategically
maybe less less dangerous tactically for
white but
here it's it's really like if if
something
will not happen soon if black doesn't
manage some very
immediate quick tactics okay he will be
lost simply so
probably giving up this bishop on d6 is
[Music]
is not really an option
rook b7 what about rook b7
yeah rugby seven i guess i'm still
playing b3
ah but now already be super five yeah
that might be a
a good idea mm-hmm yeah that makes sense
uh and six of course is critical yeah
yeah i was wondering but
yeah queen takes b2
rook takes b2 kin takes b2 queen takes
d6
what is this position i mean
if white manages to
to get mated soon he will he can be
better but
uh but his skin is really weird i think
this is at least
fine for black because yeah the king is
really unstable we should be three
inches by five for instance
if a5 also looks quite good a4 yeah
that's
i mean very serious issues with the king
but who knows in the in such
situations sometimes actually i i
wouldn't mind to give a change even yeah
i mean
if knight d3 rook d3 sometimes okay
i just need to avoid getting mated it's
much more important than
because the d5 phone is very strong but
let's see let's let's check rook b7
maybe white has another
id in his mind after b7
well it feels like we like we cannot
really
allow rook takes b2 so it's either b3 or
actually i'm thinking like bishop b3 or
b3 yeah for instance
bishop f5 knight takes d6 whoa
this maybe b3 yeah takes takes on b7
rook b7 and king c2 again i i probably
with b3 because yeah i think the b3 is
strong
b3 and then the same idea bishop f5 96
bishop c2 knight b7
i have my doubts about it but
yeah this is a very strange position i
don't know
you're sure about queen d6 move not sure
but i would like to stop g6 from
happening
i thought of something more direct maybe
like rook before trying to build knight
c4 okay for
maybe yeah that that makes a lot of
sense as well yeah that
i'm i miss that move
yeah i mean again it's uh very dangerous
for white but it might work who knows
queen c8 maybe
i quincy that means seven something like
this yeah very looks very dangerous for
waiting
very very i would rather maybe try
bishop c6 and pray yeah after look
before
[Music]
and after queen a5
[Music]
i pray and i hope that i don't get mated
yeah this is where that's pretty easy
the efficacy of prayer gets severely
tested in a position like this
a4 and okay just
[Music]
i feel like rook takes b3 should work
yeah basically but i don't see exactly
can be seen
before check ins and then we run yeah we
run the words
towards those squares yeah i
i couldn't make it work but okay yeah
it's of course very dubious so maybe
rookie b7 is
uh from from the things we've seen so
far rookie b7 does look like
it's the uh the best option yeah i would
agree
yeah and this should be yeah because if
bishop f5 if
okay maybe steal b3 and after bishop f5
i'll let you take on e4 and then i'm
trying to
like bishop effect bishop d2 may be very
solid movie i'm just trying to stop all
kind of
play uh like all uh ideas like
before and queen a5 is knight g4
[Music]
feels like it might be annoying yeah
with some knight of two ideas
[Music]
okay i will try to play maybe even f3
because actually all of a sudden my
bishop on a4 might be very strong now
i don't know about knight takes f2 by
the way
yeah by the way of course i wanted to
give up exchange but now i'm thinking
about this position
bishop is a is very powerful on a4 all
of a sudden it is yeah
i don't know if black is better here or
yeah i think if if black manages to
uh trade all the rooks along the e file
then black is probably better and if
white assumes control over the e-file i
have no idea who is better yeah i mean i
can play rookie one let's say
not sure but maybe i should try to
to do something like 94 but here here
and then
frankly even if you take this line why
should i lose it yeah
let's say if i i think 94 probably is
the best move here but even if i play
bishop c6 i know it's very double h
position
might be perfectly fine for black yeah
it could be yeah
rookie one rookie one rookie seven and
even let's say i
take which is of course very dubious
take and then trying to go 94 this is
just playing for a draw yeah if i want
to
make it i understand yeah i doubt of
course this is good but uh normally i
should of course keep that with a pair
of rooks yeah yeah
i think i think well here i would start
feeling a lot happier with black because
i think
even though here black has no risk at
all but i doubt he can really win it i
mean takes and g3 because i also my d
phone can
start to run one day yeah yeah g3 is a
very important move
even some ideas sometimes before can be
three bishop takes before
it's very very strange position very
strange but
might not be so simple but objectively
maybe i should keep a rope but this is
an interesting way for white to play
yeah this
afternoon b7 absolutely yeah absolutely
and uh
and maybe after d3 black can again try
to play
b3 and there's also this idea of just
playing something like rook before yeah
yeah that's what i
thought but the question is after bishop
d2 still i don't know if you really
achieve something significant by this
exchange sacrifice
maybe not yeah maybe not
because there's no immediate follow-up
[Music]
it looks nice to give yourself this this
gorgeous open file but i don't know what
i'm doing with it
bishop f5 is logical but still what rook
he won and it's not so obvious
that black has enough compensation here
because somehow white is
white covers all squares yeah
so yeah it's very very sharp position
after 94
yeah this should be uh should be a very
exciting game because magnus now has to
take some very difficult decisions
uh how to how to continue with his
initiative
it feels like if he if he doesn't uh if
he doesn't do well in the next i don't
know two three moves
you could very easily imagine white
completely stabilizing and just
being being a healthy protected past
born up
which would be obviously very good for
him
true true so let's see maybe uh the
ferocious game so b5 knight h5 was
played
yeah knight h5 after some prolonged
thinking by
uh bayern not so logical
it's a logical of course but it's very
risky move i mean now
um black wants just to mate kind of yeah
because
but my experience shows that it's quite
difficult to make in such italians and
otherwise
i mean i guess id is knight gf4 probably
yeah but this is a little bit all in
yeah because if you if you don't
actually achieve your objectives on the
king side you will
you will allow some kind of b6
uh for for white and and that
might be quite painful yeah but from the
point of view this rook g6 is uh
it's quite a it's a serious threat yeah
it's a serious threat yeah so bishop
takes a four maybe
or knight f4 and now it seems like
all i need is just flipping it yeah yeah
yeah and i'm not quite
not quite clear to me how to stop it
yeah because even keen h2 rook g6
is so maybe not knight c4 maybe knight
c4 is over optimistic
what do we do then oh
of 12 in the worst case knight f1 is
always possible yeah
but it's probably not the was not
this is what he played but how do like
why does this
why does this help against knight f4
uh it helps at minimum helps
ecologically your knight is closer to
the king so
you feel safer somehow no but knight g3
maybe simply
yeah but we've had this discussion i
think if if this happens um
ah yeah yeah uh maybe king h2 then maybe
should i try to at least to force you
first to play yeah maybe maybe this
makes a lot of sense seeking h2 rook g6
knight g3
because open g6 unless uh you're not
getting
mated but knight takes g2 might be an
option yeah
i i don't know knight g2 if it works
yeah the point being king takes g2
knight f4 check but i don't like because
bishop before ef4 and then your bishop
on a7 becomes yeah then we just pass and
we allow you
yeah yeah yeah the bishop is bad for
yeah forever
almost so this i'm not sure but uh
yeah knight f1 i still not quite sure
why then
why not knight f1 immediately but okay
yeah let's uh
i mean why knight f1
was not played one move earlier but
let's see so knight f1
can we play rook of s no rook f6 i guess
white is intending to play knight
knight one h2 very typical yeah very
typical move to try to
everything is protected five times and
uh
but this is exactly my question is it
actually protected enough
enough times anyway if i go knight of
four here and rook g6 is back
back to being quite an annoying threat
right yes i'm thinking now if
yeah what can i do can h1 rook g1 or
something in the worst case yeah
king h1 yeah i guess i'll come i guess
i'm being a little bit over optimistic
if i suggest no no i'm not sure
i mean it might work but kg2 yeah
because
i think you know even h1r g1 maybe
yeah all that as well yeah i've i it
feels like i'm i'm
making some progress but i just don't
have enough attackers right
i will just i will just run out of well
to put another way white has
too many defenders yeah both both both
of those are true here you know it feels
like
quite difficult to mate i remember i had
a game with sasha grishou
rapid chess we just had two knights
against two knights and i put all my
pieces in even rook was on g6 but it was
actually very difficult to create
threats
i've managed to trick somehow but it was
yeah i was quite surprised how difficult
it is to create real threats
in this position so if white is careful
yeah usually this attack is not
is not a mating one yeah
tonight f1 but maybe after knight f1
let's come back to the game
maybe some kind of move like aba b rook
f8 i would consider just some
you know makes a lot of sense takes or
don't take and rook f8 maybe somewhere
f5 can come after all
there are no threats really for white
no not really it does give me a tempo to
play something like usb
3 but which should generally be quite
useful but
yeah that is useful and uh but then
still
so of course you're threatening d5 but
is it a big threat
yeah i mean if i play bishop b6 or
something and just
position me because now at least white
knight white's knight is not going to c4
not attacking the bishop
[Music]
and if if you do play g5 here these
types of positions
you are probably not very
worried about with black even if we kind
of ignore the fact that i
might be able to might even might even
have rook takes f3 yeah
but also cb as it looks quite quite a
lot of initiative for black yeah yeah
but even after cb
exploiting this eventual weakness on b6
is not going to be very easy and there
is going to be quite a lot of immediate
initiative on the king side yeah
so maybe this is a way to play for black
now i mean
now let's see because in our previous
reports and in our previous streams i o
i
uh express this opinion that uh the
problem of aryan that he he likes to
play very very direct chair that
sometimes he is
forgetting i mean just to improve
quietly his position
and i think maybe now it's it's a time
uh to to make a couple of useful moves
because i'm not sure this very
straightforward way of playing will work
and yeah let's see again let's see if uh
also i wanted to bring something up you
played rook f8 there but
maybe you know those mysterious rook
moves as they were called in the books
of our youth maybe
we can make up less mysterious moves
here and
still make some sense and what about
even less mysterious move bishop b6
yeah i mean it makes a lot of sense if
you have the a
line yeah yeah exactly yeah i mean
usually my experience chess experience
shows that the less mysterious is the
move the better is
is is it yeah yeah
[Music]
i think i think it's very possible that
this is this is okay although
it kind of it paints a target here so
maybe 93 with the ideas of
but then already knight f4 maybe yeah
then
yeah but i i i now do have the option of
playing knight g4 eventually so i don't
know
am i am i guessing mated again or not
not immediately probably but uh
black species are all very very very
i mean very active yeah yeah
[Music]
i mean it doesn't look like it's a big
deal for i mean complicated position so
now we have
uh fiona yeah with us
we are being joined by by fiona from
from hello good evening so you you've
got some
fresh cookies for us yeah some tweets
uh avert the games today we have had
some big names uh tweeting at us
today so the first one is david howell
and because it's actually well his
pet line that magnus has employed today
this he takes f6
karokan i don't know if you can see the
tweet on the screen already
i can't maybe peter uh either way so
david tweeted carlson played my beloved
uh he takes f6 carol basically a first
win for black this part
it's humor but he he loves his clara can
and then he says that although magnus
said he would never play it again
after the 2018 ecc game against uh
zwiddler
yeah he's he's played it since so that
was clearly a lie
peter did he say anything at the time
what did you guys discuss
after the game we were mainly we were
mainly talking about the technical end
game that i got in that game and uh
i i expressed the opinion that basically
with colors reversed white wins every
single time and uh
even during the game i felt that you
know if this is a carlson swiddler game
everybody knows it ends with the white
victory but because it's a sweet like
carlson game
everybody kind of knows it's it's a draw
so uh
and that that ended up being true but uh
we did not discuss the opening so much
and then the the second tweet also about
the magnus game
ivan zokolov has tweeted at us once
again
and he responded to a terrier treat
where terry was saying
that this is another example or terry
was asking is this another example of
carlson taking risks to win with black
and yvonne retweeted saying not really
that much risk
this ponzac has solid positional
fundament
uh also again like against harry he's
playing against the men
not easy for do that to handle this type
of position with his confidence level
which is presumably low
so what do you make of that how much do
you think magnus choice was
motivated by his opponent and also his
result in this tournament
i think that's very fair i think uh i
think he definitely played
a significant part he has played this
line before and uh
i think you know despite maybe swearing
at some point he'll never do it again it
was always
going to be at least slightly possible
[Music]
didn't take so much risk i mean it it
was well justified if let's say
uh playing this d5 ed5 ef5 against uh
arientari was uh
uh somehow really
really risky i mean strategically in all
other senses here i mean yeah it was a
justify i mean
knight f6 f6 it's a very serious line
nowadays
actually very well assessed by computers
as i understand
and this pawn sacrifice was was very
promising and actually it's i think it
was just objectively very good
i don't know if he treated after the
position in the right manner but
i don't think it was too much risk i
mean just a sharp game
and i personally would have played like
this
against any opponent even even carson
himself is black i just
find it good very sound objectively
which is maybe was not the case uh in
the
in the previous black game against iris
so that
yeah i'm not sure there is so much
psychology in it yeah
i mean it's not impossible that if if he
would have been playing arenan or
caruana he would he wouldn't go for it
still
yeah i will for sure i will ask magnus
about this also i know that the hosts
here of the norwegian
uh tv show where also today for example
he's sitting right next to me neil
scoendelius
has joined the show who was on magnus's
team at the time when this game against
peter
was played and he said they were
wondering if this b5 how much of it
was prep how much of it was a bluff so
i'm curious
to hear what what magnus will have to
say on the topic
and finally my last tweet i don't know
if you guys have already discussed
yesterday's rest
uh rest day activities or did you see
what happened
no we haven't discussed it yet but we
were waiting for you to tell us what was
happening and
did someone there to eat those cakes
well unfortunately unfortunately not we
didn't get to taste them but i think
maybe it was for the best so i don't
know if the treat is being shown but
basically everyone should head to our
website because leonard
otis took some fantastic photos some
very fun photos of the players you know
decorating the cakes and the results and
i don't know if you know who won the
competition we know
but uh but you can announce it to all of
our spectators
well the winner was a lebaneronian and
levon was delighted because
he was still upset that the last two
years he had always come in last place
in the cooking competition and he said
this was so unfair because he's the only
player out there
yeah he actually cooks
but cooking cooking and decorating is
not really the same yeah
but he basically he won the competition
and it was uh judged by one of uh
norway's top chefs and he won the
competition because the chef said
levon was basically the only one who
used the chocolate in between the layers
so it was a tree layered cake
and for example alireza his cake i
thought looked very nice but he didn't
use
any of the chocolate so it would be i'm
glad we didn't taste it
because it would be extremely dry simply
maybe he took it with him to his hotel
room yeah
instead yeah but still yeah still i mean
of course
my big achievement one of my biggest
supportive achievement is
winning the cow milk in competition some
three years ago
together with wesley saw so that was
yeah i'm very proud still of this
yeah and who knows i mean next year i
was just talking to benedicta the main
organizer here earlier she said next
year they will try
to switch away now they had a lot of
cooking and baking
so maybe next year we will go back to
the farm uh
with the farm again and i guess it would
be a very different
oh yes remember i remember we we had a
kind of uh
biathlon yeah of uh uh with the truck
driving
and uh and cow milking yeah tractor yeah
you're right driving was a bit difficult
because it was my first time actually
driving anything
in my life yes so i didn't do it that
well even if wesley
wesley he was part of our team he did
better so there we
we got a kind of reasonable result and
and
in uh we were totally unstoppable in cow
milking i mean i think
we managed like twice as an amount as a
second place because
somehow we really got the right approach
you know to our beautiful cow and she
was very generous so
for you it's one of your highlights for
me it's one of the biggest pities in my
life that i was not here to see this
because i would have loved love love
to witness this at this event but yeah
so that was what happened yesterday
and i think most importantly i thought
the players all had fun
and uh and yeah and i'm sure people will
see that for themselves if they check
out
the photos and that's that's all for me
for now at least yeah thank you thank
you very much fiona so
uh uh yeah you can go everyone can go
and check the photos
i've done already even a couple of
videos um
and we then probably continue oh yeah
and i just
of course the people can also see the
the video actually so i did a facebook
live so if they go to our facebook page
they don't only see the photos
but they can watch the whole thing uh in
video and see the
the players decorate the cakes and all
that so check out the facebook and the
the photos on the website
thank you for having me see you later
yeah see you later thanks uh
thanks for coming stopping by and uh and
with that we are back to
uh let's check the quran maybe there's
some some
serious things are happening there
yeah let's come back to the position
after queen a5 so yeah
we left it here and fabi after some
thought decided to
just completely decline the invitation
to uh
you know try and refute it uh uh
straight away he played
one actually one bishop takes c4 knight
c1 uh
stabilizing the situation on the queen
side but also
uh giving up the pawn on c4 we won't
play bishop f7
i'm slightly curious why g4 is not a
move you play even here
uh rook g5 rog5 yes sorry rogue d5
exists of course yeah
this is uh this is the tactical
justification the the fork still doesn't
pick up any material because rook d5 is
just in time to sidestep it
so fabi took on f6 uh levon finally
brought the
the errand uh knight from from the rim
to f6 and
the final move so far is uh five play
queen c6 attacking of course the rook on
e8 and seemingly the knight on d7
although
uh i don't think you absolutely have to
protect it for instance i think rook e8
is a move you could try here attacking
the bishop
[Music]
there's bishop g6 in the end right yeah
i want to maybe bishop c4
i mean queen takes d7 here i was trying
to calculate the
b c and maybe bishop c4 you do have
bishop c4 here and
just for our viewers the reason you
cannot just take a full rook here is
there is bishop g6 which
picks up the queen after bishop c4 but i
thought black is just fine
let's say even if i just give you the
stroke and play some kind of a normal
move here uh
maybe even just push through seven back
well the queen c7 you know something
yeah
yeah i think i think it's just a fine
position but okay
so let's say what after okay let's think
uh maybe bishop d3 bishop dc
bishop g3 i generally wanted to put it
on on
on d5 anyway there's also 95.
i'm not sure but uh first of all queen
takes c5 who knows i think this doesn't
though yeah he's 93
i'm not sure because knight gets to c4
knight takes e8
bishop takes a five knight c4 and uh
it's really scary it's scary yeah but
maybe even
one yeah even the fruity one or
something yeah not clear if
uh because we did manage to trade a lot
of the heavy pieces away so we're not
getting mated so easy
the second knight might get to b5 at
some point
yeah very sharp yeah very sharp position
knight b3 ideas are possible
[Music]
uh so if i don't play 95 if i if i make
up
a quieter move for now
[Music]
and also like one point i wanted to make
is that let's say
we end up if we end up playing some kind
of an end game like this this is
completely fine for black now definitely
yeah
yeah so black doesn't really have to
worry even about
having to switch to uh to an end game
anymore
um and rookie eight uh uh has
has been actually played by by level he
just
made that move okay
yeah magnus is still in very deep
yeah magnus is still in the tank it's
quite remarkable i think i think this is
let me let me just briefly check because
it's it's interesting i think he's been
thinking for uh 32 minutes it says on my
screen
and let's say let's see what this may be
first atari doing because
uh yeah uh already his eyes
and actually he's probably right he's
just saying that okay mate me
and for now i'm just trying to to get
some
uh you know uh advantages on the queen
side and it's
yeah rugby seven rugby seven is a very
annoying threat actually so if
if black doesn't make enough progress on
the other side and the thing is that i
believe he wants after knight f4 now he
takes bishop to xf1
puts knight on g3 yeah which is very
very solid
and then keen h2 and it's very difficult
to do something about it
yeah the bishop on a7 is is kind of cut
off which is
one reason why you could make an
argument for what we were doing
uh in our analysis we were always more
or less always
including a b and b and then making a
move yeah
but now maybe maybe black can try to get
fc6 at some point yeah it's
i don't know how how dangerous or even
c5 what about c5
it's a very strange move but it's just
tactical yeah my idea is d5 rook f6
threatening rook takes f3 and next c4 is
as quick as possible
to open up this bishop
back i don't know
not sure really it will work because
it's a very concrete idea yeah
maybe between d1 and also c5 g takes e5
maybe yeah yeah true
knight t5 was my idea but yeah but
it takes a row case i suspect yeah yeah
it depends on whether i can say you have
to try yes
but the bishop on a7 is so bad that even
even if you just give up e4
pawn i'm not sure it's going to be good
for black it's just exactly yeah
i was hoping to find a good good pawn
sacrifice here yeah even bishop b2
and it doesn't look good 93 just yeah it
takes only four
it's just awful bishop on e7 yeah
yeah there's there's definitely a lot of
compensation for
for the pawn maybe black is not doing
so poorly but it's definitely very very
playable for white
yeah d5 i would actually be worried
about g5 more than i would be about
g5 yeah yeah you're all right now c5 was
just an idea but
but yeah i i have my doubts about this
move
so maybe instead of c5 c6
yeah c6 is is a concession obviously
because it's not really the move you
like to play in this
in those type of positions but maybe
there is no big choice anymore
and also maybe we just play g5 next move
with black yeah maybe we just actually
try to
trade everything away in the center and
claim that the resulting position is not
going to be very bad because of
how many how much material will get
traded away
yeah that might work because if bishop
b3
maybe you can first of all still play d5
yeah
also ed4 i'm not sure if it's uh yeah
default forces bishop takes i guess
[Music]
yeah so maybe c6 finally
and at least we pick up the the the
central pawn here
uh yeah seemed to have been
no queen c8 was played
[Music]
he stops through b7 protects the pawn on
a6
the only minus is that queen on c8 is
yeah it's maybe a little bit passive i
mean
but it doesn't support the g5 counter
play anymore so you
are more committed to creating something
on the king side i guess
i don't know i mean it's a playable move
but maybe there was something more
concrete
with white i i guess the most natural
move in the position is bishop p3 i
don't know if there is anything
yeah bishop i guess it takes d4 has to
be
or i i just want to mention that maybe
there is a point in queen b3
just completely ignoring the pawn on e4
but trying to land queen bc
yeah that's a very very interesting
option yeah
queen b7 might actually win a lot of
material if it happens
maybe ed5 84 and c5 somehow trying to go
c4 at some point and then maybe yeah
let's say i guess i mean shockingly i
think i can even play it here
[Music]
if if i really want to go sort of all in
on this idea i can even maybe play it
here
yeah maybe you can ask the question
dx3 of course is a strange move but
yeah but i don't know if i don't believe
it will be enough
it doesn't doesn't feel quite it's true
that yeah this through that queen b3 is
creating this
uh queen b7 threat yeah queen b3 is a is
a very concrete idea which uh
i have no idea if this is good or not
but it it does make the game suddenly
very
very sharply tactical maybe rook six is
seven
yeah yeah that's clever it's a it's a
very sad move of course to
to play but the idea is queen b7 maybe
c5 c6
i don't know which one is right but in
general rook on e7 is
i'm afraid there will be a lot of
tactical ideas like 93 for example i
mean it doesn't look like
ed knight d5 and then again queen b7 and
looks very dubious yeah
but queen b3 yes queen b3 is uh
it's at least something to consider i
don't know if it's i don't know if it's
strong but it's definitely something to
consider with white here
um very easy and i'm pretty even sure
that
it's a it looks like a very interesting
move and
might be played yeah so let's go finally
finally magnus here he have played
his move after more than half
half an hour in the tank he does go
rookie b7 which is the move we expected
and now now but yeah still b3 uh
i don't know i don't know if it's so
clear yeah b3
i think probably will be played
[Music]
of course bishop f5 is the most natural
here
yeah it's it's either bishop f5 or that
exchange sacrifice that i mentioned but
bishop five looks better
yeah it looks like and now the question
first of all here there is this bishop
d2 move
maybe bishop d2 knight c4 here and then
rook before that is really
too much that is that is maybe too much
because steel knight takes d6 will be
yeah but five six still exists you know
yeah this should be four
before knight takes d6 yeah
and yeah black doesn't doesn't really
come out i have 26 queen c3 there is no
mate
[Music]
even if c4 you can still try but okay
it's for
for one minute bullet game or more
yeah it doesn't doesn't normally work
out things like that so after bcd
i mean bishop d2 is a move but i quite
like this queen sacrifice how was it
going
i don't remember already yeah we we
played
yeah yeah i think and then you played f3
here yeah yeah i don't know if knight g4
yeah maybe
let's try to think here maybe what about
trying rook before anyway
wow really no
not really i mean but what do we try it
takes takes a look before
uh so your threat is sort of some kind
of slow
queen a5 knight c4 some ideas are okay
for you i
doubt of course
that is quite remarkable yeah maybe
even just yeah that's maybe the best
thing is
[Music]
just go a3 and then slowly slowly
consolidate with like a three year okay
but even yeah if you
if you consolidate that yeah it's must
be too much yeah
unless knight takes c4 here maybe
is a way to become very sad very quickly
yeah and if vc4 maybe i can take yeah
knight acidity check is possible
[Music]
uh so here we go and now bishop
up you should prefer check again no this
is fantastic for black yeah so a3 is
just not a move i guess
so rookie one probably looks very slow
does it even help
i mean oh you still won't has has enough
changed for this not to work is my
question
i don't know this is a very
striking thread because
[Music]
maybe yeah and now
uh knight takes six i've missed knight
f6 yeah no no but gf i mean
it's queen f5 i'm not sure rugby one
czech yeah
this actually works out for black
somehow yeah yeah
of course it's it's all extremely
speculative like this is not forced but
yeah
by far yeah i mean but uh
yeah this partition becomes very
double-edged i mean it's very easy
uh to to get also worse with black
already
i mean under certain circumstances so
rook b4 b3 frankly doesn't look like i
have no good defense against yeah
against those
half threats yeah there should be
something we i
you have to assume we're missing
something simple here but i don't see it
and another idea by the way i i start to
think
that's probably too much is to play
knight take c4 immediately and then
uh where uh b3 do we play bishop five or
not
no no i mean here bishop f5 bishop d2
yeah
yeah bishop d2 uh yes my no no probably
doesn't work yeah sorry i had some
yeah we tried knight c4 here but it
didn't seem to it didn't seem to work
so but what is right next
he wants just slowly to start
consolidating you
maybe bishop c3 is very double h i don't
know if we can allow knight takes e4
yeah yeah but the thing
is and what is uh i mean it's not so
easy maybe to make
any really constructive move for for
white
that is true that is true it's a
not really a mutual such one but yeah
it's very unclear who is who is aiming
for what
uh and how to how to improve white
probably wants rookie one but even this
is
not really uh a huge improvement yeah
yeah your next move remains unclear
after that
yeah so maybe some different options
like bishop g6 might be interesting
trying even to go bishop f eight next
and then f5
for instance yeah so we want bishop and
then maybe a five of four
yeah looks extremely slow but after all
why not yeah
very possibly very possibly and uh oh
bishop of f8 first yeah
whatever yeah and uh yeah it's
very hard to say what's what is the
position yeah
it feels like on the other hand for uh
for young stuff here it feels like he
really should be playing b3 because
i think we we are in agreement yeah
let's check knight d6 but uh
but it look it's really look bad yeah
yeah i don't think i don't think this is
this is going to be uh very good like
white might
be able to survive if he plays really
precisely afterwards but
you know this this position just looks
very very dangerous for white
i don't think you can afford to do it
yeah we bishop d3 and
yeah i even i even uh really worried
about a5 yeah i think a5 is a very
strong because a4 is a very annoying
threat yeah and
uh and and bishop bishop b3 really
doesn't look right it
it's just like a5 even if bishop f5 even
it's
just doing the same but just uh one day
five a4 will
arrive yeah absolutely yes so it feels
like
uh once again it's uh it's something i
i get very fixated upon that well
young chisholm made a few moves quite
quickly in this game
and now he is spending i think
a lot more time than it is practically
viable on on this decision in particular
because i think
you know considering this time control
probably even i
would be kind of forced to calculate on
your opponent my opponent's time you
know normally i get up and i do
something else but
yeah same same as me yeah but uh but
frankly black had only two
two moves yeah bishop f5 which probably
was not working
because of knight f6 and then rook b7
the rest of the moves were just not good
yes so
not very good yeah i guess rook b7 yeah
you usually
calculate and yeah it's very the time
management is
very strange i mean of of the polish
player yeah
yeah i i don't i don't quite i don't
quite understand uh
how he uh how he decides
where to where to think for a long time
yeah because because to my understanding
i mean
it looks like b3 is almost the only uh
unless we miss something yeah but it's
almost like only
move at least practically in practical
sense yeah because oh
yeah maybe maybe we are missing
something here but uh
i can't in this particular case i don't
think i don't think we are
yeah i don't i can't really imagine even
what what does other ideas yeah
for white yeah and uh yeah i i don't
know
i don't have much experience playing
these uh
slightly non-standard time controls with
like 90 minutes or 120 as
it is here for the entire game uh but i
do imagine that it becomes
it becomes a lot more important to to
manage your time wisely
yes because it's a very it's a very very
unforgiving
time control you if you uh
if you find yourself with very little
time and still a lot of very difficult
like tactical decisions to be made you
are extremely likely to start making bad
mistakes
uh so yeah i think i think b3
probably needed to be played slightly
faster
yeah so let's see uh 11's game yeah what
is knight
went to b8 for somebody yeah this is a
bit this is a bit shocking to me i i
i don't quite understand maybe there is
a tactical justification of it yeah that
there is a
it's not so clear where the queen
i guess yeah queen b5 he just wants to
go queen c7 and continue
there is c4 possible by the way after
queen b5
maybe it's not such a bad idea i just go
for this end game yeah and uh
yeah because the points are limiting
white i mean bishop g6 check it
somewhere i mean the pawns are really
very annoying this before knight gets to
c6 this actually makes
this starts starts making a lot more
sense to me because i
i somehow thought because you know i'm
famously
uh there are very few people in the
world who you know value the bishops
more than i do so for me
i thought there is no way black can be
playing an end game here unless you take
on b6 like i was showing a line where
black was
trading queens on the b6 square
improving his structure a great deal
and uh yeah i just did not for one
second consider the idea of trading
queens here but it does look
very long yeah but it looks like white
really has very bad pieces yeah if he
could have his bishop on c2 and some but
now it's like black has a lot of
initiative here yeah it's so difficult
for white to get his pieces
in a sensitive in the sensible squares
so maybe not queen b5 if i play if i
play really slowly
do i get mated or i don't know about
getting mated even
although even this is very possible like
d3 yeah like immediate b3 looks very
scary this is very
scary because uh uh
you might but uh also some knight c6
ideas but
yeah it's yeah i was wondering if if
maybe i have enough time to like play
bish p2 play rook he one then put it
back on f1 and start trading
yeah but probably it's a little bit too
slow uh
the other option there's really only two
i mean queen b7 exists but i don't
believe in it
the other option would be to play queen
d6 here
yeah it's not really something here
peter what
you would love to do yeah no not really
just c4 it feels like it's like the same
position we were just discussing
queens on yeah which is not an
improvement probably the mate will come
rather soon here so but
maybe it seems to me like queen b5 is
almost the
only reasonable choice yeah yeah and now
after queen b5
yeah of course c4 is not obligatory you
can also try
to go away with the queen but i think c4
is most probably is
levon's idea yeah because quincy seven
for instance allows bishop c4 which
makes white's life
immediately slightly easier to manage
even here
i'm pretty sure c4 will be the the c4 is
the point
you have to take yeah we absolutely have
to take now because otherwise why we
played queen b5
and yeah you have to look for a move
here for white and i i don't know what
that move is
i will think about move b3 it's of
course the but at least i want to get my
but
knight d5 is very scary yeah
95 i have to play bishop d4
very very dangerous very boring for
white very boring but who knows maybe
if i manage i'm
[Music]
yeah doesn't doesn't seem to be
immediately collapsing but yeah it's
uh but it might i mean it might like
knight c6 for example i'm saying i
i don't see how i lose after bishop
takes yeah
yeah because i have to take a knight ccd
check i think i can
maybe even play king b2 which probably
ends up being some kind of a draw
yeah yeah
but here yes rook takes a2 is a drop i
mean bishop c4 you want to take with
what
if i if i want to pretend i'm playing
for a win i have to take with the pawn
but then there's this so i'm not playing
for a win anyway so yeah
yeah yeah i mean black is fine but at
least here so maybe b3 if it works
of course white black can also get his
pawn to c3
she's oh but then the idea is to try at
least i get my squares yeah my bishop dc
bishop c2 knight gets to d3 so i can get
even even though i'm not completely sure
because opponent c3 is still
still a serious force yeah yeah it's uh
it's quite
it's quite scary as well yeah i was also
looking at we can include knight g5
bishop d4
i could also i was wondering if i'm
supposed to throw in bishop six check
here
yeah king a1 and then maybe play but c3
bishop c4 is awkward here i don't know
i'm not actually making as much progress
as i'd hoped
yeah you can yeah probably two exists
but i guess bishops
quite happy yeah yeah this is just a
dream yeah knight gets to d3 and so on
so probably maybe this is a way to
uh
does seem like the best choice we've
seen so far yeah i was also
slowly coming to the conclusion as we
were yeah i'm not i'm just not quite
sure about
c3 at this position if i manage c3 let's
say
let's say bishop d3 i suspect and then
the idea is i don't know rg5
or whatever just to make and then just
to have a pawn on a5
uh yeah i mean if i just get my pawn to
a5 and knight to c6
yeah this looks completely fine for
black at least yeah no
black i think black is perfectly fine
here just the question is if he is
better or not yes i mean
that's for me uh a serious question i
know frog g5 for knight c6 and then
trying to get the rook into a better
square than g5 yeah because
but anyway and not so important maybe
white will i'm not sure about rook g1
because maybe i want
uh maybe it's better to make another
move just to be able to get my rook to
be one like
something like g4 or geo
and then a5 and rookie one and trying to
change rooks and knight will get to c6
one day uh
yeah we could maybe even take yeah
basically
we yeah because strangely enough this
king
even if it's a end game it's still
still a long-term problem for white
it's still not not so funny in this
knight on c1
so i still would say that probably it's
black who is pressing here
in this particular position yeah but i i
think this is probably
okay for white long term i think white
probably makes a draw eventually
um yeah yeah i don't know
uh yeah i really like to be white yeah
yeah
i'm not not really dreaming of proving
proving myself correct here honestly the
more
the more i look at this the the less i
would like to be
but what is interesting yeah finally
queen b5 has been played
so let's see let's guess
[Music]
yeah i think c4 is probably the
explanation for knight b8 but i mean
queen c7 is
is still playable maybe i'm not sure
about also bishop g3 it looks very
unpleasant yeah bishop g3 just
trying to we should just yeah
goals and i don't really see where yeah
i yeah queen c8 is already
a huge concession because i have the
source i can take on b8 at some point
yeah
but also also you no longer have queen
takes f7 yeah yeah no that is what these
positions are
no that is so probably c4 is a move
now by the way bishop e3 i was played by
firouza and i
think i get the point i get the point
because
edc d probably he wants just to
sacrifice a pony like this and then
trying to it's quite typical also and
then maybe at some point queen c6 and
trying to catch
uh yeah finish this bishop on a7 yeah
that also happens yeah
like maybe even immediately
[Music]
but i guess i go knight of six and i try
to get 97 in and if you play queen b7
there's also
there's always queen a8 so i don't
actually lose the bishop straight away
[Music]
maybe queen takes c7 is playable here
yeah i was hoping for knight g5 but then
queen takes this
i thought maybe even uh i don't know if
rugby seven first of all was uh
was an option yeah uh
rugby sound knight is ah yeah you you
have context
i don't know yeah it's not completely
clear because maybe d4 is hanging
on bishop d4 knight d4 rook before
yeah that probably is quite important
actually
ma rook takes c7 queen somewhere i don't
know maybe even where
that's kind of active square
[Music]
who knows it's very tactical but uh but
it looks like black should have enough
play yeah
it feels like probably probably ends up
being some kind of yeah
so maybe yeah but i think this idea is
interesting after cd rookie four maybe
even some
you know quiet play just slowly try to
uh first of all there is a move knight
d2 maybe trying to ask
to ask the rook where would it go uh e7
i think uh yeah because e6 d5 yeah maybe
yeah
now and now queen c6 because now
i want to
yeah rugby 7 is a threat now i guess you
know though i always have queen a8
i will take on a6 and um yeah it's an
interesting way of playing of course
black
might try to get some certain counter
attack
yeah on the as it usually had light hf4
and igfo and knight h maybe
who knows knight h3 might be enough for
a draw
under certain conditions i mean we have
to be careful with white also
because rook b7 still takes time to take
on a7 the rook is
out of play and maybe black can create
threats
like even knight x h3 who knows
just how do i give mate queen takes h3 i
want knight f
neither four another four is a threat
here yeah so let's see if there is
knight h2
but it's it's tricky yeah i mean yeah
here knight f4
knight h2 rookie four maybe rookie four
wow
yeah it's very easy to just get
completely blown okay bishop takes f4
maybe still works rookie one knight f1
but yeah it's
it's very tricky even though it's not
completely clear if white black will not
have some resources
like rook e4 rook 84 who knows
probably not probably not enough this
already feels like maybe this is a
little bit
too much but it must be yeah it's an
illustration it's an illustration that
white can not really
yeah because rook on a7 you see so many
temples to take this bishop yeah
mm-hmm so uh we're getting we're getting
ahead of ourselves a little bit is there
anything else apart from e takes d4 in
this position that you can play with
black and
not being there i guess d5 is a threat
uh
yeah this is d5 also yeah probably at
minimum
i don't really see what what can be done
yeah it feels like you you might have to
accept if we assume this is a pawn
sacrifice because
uh just to illustrate if you take with
the bishop trying to keep the pawn c5
still
still that might be another way to
sacrifice the polonie after playing
bishop e3 and trying to play against
this bishop a7 yeah
but it doesn't looks to me it doesn't
seem to be so
uh impressive
no maybe it's kind of compensation
knight d2 maybe 92 trying to go knight
c4 one day
yeah but it feels like here black is a
lot is a lot more in control right queen
f6 i want to play g5 the knight returns
to f6
yeah and again unless there is some very
direct solution queen f5 and maybe
very very you know directly it can work
knight f6 bishop h6 who knows but but
doesn't look yeah i
fully agree with him it doesn't look see
even takes only one and then d5
doesn't look too too bad for black yeah
and uh briefly we will return to this in
a moment but
uh fabi found a very interesting idea
here he just goes rogue d4
obviously i think with the intention of
immediately giving this exchange
uh on the c4 square take stakes i guess
king goes to h8 we go
either knight b3 or rook d1 i guess
knight b3 and then maybe rook c1 or
something yeah
yeah must be okay for black
it must be fine but i'm not sure
uh if uh black will allow this uh
exchange sacrifice
uh how do you rook c8 or morocco c5
maybe
or roxy yeah roxy five is a bit awkward
though because of the
the x-ray icon why not rook c8 just
but roxy5 at least what is good about
this move maybe
i want to get my knight out
but still knight c6 is not threatening
because of rook d6 so
but let's say i want just to play five
next
bishop i suspect him probably bishop to
i i don't really see any very useful
jumps and we have the
the first quote from the confessional
today uh madness played rook b7 and then
uh while uh young shirt was considering
b3 he went he went in and he said
it became a really complicated game
today i sucked upon for an attack
against
his king spent a long time on my last
move rook b7 i don't know why i don't
have any many alternatives
i have calculated b3 i will play uh rook
b4 which he has already done
uh by the way uh with the idea to take
on c4 with the knight or with the rook
on a4
it seems very very exciting but i don't
know how well it works
but he is obviously concerned that he
spends uh so much time on b3 which seems
to me the obvious reply it will be super
exciting to see what he what he comes up
with because it's not obvious at all
so yeah looks like magnus is also very
uh unsure about the objective assessment
of the position
which is not surprising it's just such a
messy position
to play and he used the word exciting i
think four or five times in that little
quote so
he must be excited he must be excited
yeah
but yes i guess
[Music]
he usually prefers not to be excited
during game just just to have a very
nice position and slowly press it home
you know
so i don't know if it's a good sign if
he is excited
i think these days he's actually kind of
consciously trying to
trying to play more more exciting chess
and we're now competing with magnus
as to how many times we can use that
word in the next 30 seconds
uh i think he
i don't know if that was your impression
but it really seems to me like he
uh is is like actively trying to play
sharper
whenever possible that's true that's
that's this i i agree with it but
uh yeah sometimes
is maybe taking too much risk of course
i'm the last person to
to tell it yeah uh but uh
it seems that yeah it's maybe sometimes
it's on the age of taking too much risk
but we will see usually he is getting
out
well uh from such situations
no i don't say his worse i guess it's
just extremely complicated yeah
yeah but it's obvious that he takes
risks already quite seriously
and honestly from once again he doesn't
address the question directly but from
that quote
uh it seems to me like uh
the sacrifice may have been a bit of a
of an
over-the-board bluff because um
like the general tone of what he's
saying doesn't he doesn't sound like a
man who
at least up to a certain point had like
a clear
answer uh prepared i think
he is just very much enjoying that
young sister gave him the option of
playing such a game today
and he is clearly happy that this is
happening but
doesn't actually know
[Music]
what what is happening exactly well we
will ask him yeah we'll uh
hopefully if we will ask him yeah
so this so maybe we can uh have a small
break now what do you think peter
because since this it seems like
positions are
uh more or less quiet people are
thinking they have
uh enough reasons for it and uh we can
um i'll never come back in a few minutes
in 10 minutes and
continue and some things will be
happening already i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we wanted to do a historical top 50
of
uh chess players of sort of all time and
to
to do that we are using um the
statistics by
jeff sonax who has created a site called
chessmetrics we've gotten some help from
uh
frank hofmeister who is a well-renowned
jessie historian but then
we have still kind of added our our own
touch and
it's always going to be subjective and
there's simply there's no correct answer
i hope you guys
enjoyed and i hope you agree with every
single
ranking because usually when you public
lists what could go wrong who would
disagree with anything
but yeah it's been it's been fun and i
hope you like it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
the fire is strong
but i don't care
[Music]
is
[Music]
think about it later
[Music]
welcome back and uh we are
once again bringing you all the action
from round five of the ltbox 2020 norway
chess tournament
and we start with the uh corona running
game because that is the
the game in which a move has been made
shockingly and it is a move we
uh expected to a degree uh as we
mentioned before going on the break
uh five played rook g4 with a very clear
idea
of sacrifice i mean attacking the
opponent c4 and perhaps even
quite quite certainly i think
sacrificing the exchange
uh to get his pieces out of the corner
in the king's side
on the king's side and rook c8 is aiming
to prevent that because
restricting the bishop on f1 and the
knight on c1 with this pawn on c4
is very much part of what he is trying
to achieve here
yeah i might be trying to get a better
version
you